kumusta ang aking pangalan ay Olivia Lan at ako ay isang mananaliksik at tagapagturo sa IBM Quantum ang video na ito ay nagtatanda ng paglulunsad ng isang
bagong serye sa Qiskit YouTube channel at sa aming learning platform na tinatawag na Quantum Computing in
Practice sa madaling salita sa seryeng ito ipapakita ko sa iyo kung paano gamitin ang isang quantum computer na umiiral ngayon sa kanyang
buong potensyal may bilyun-bilyong video na sa internet tungkol sa mga quantum computer at sa kanilang potensyal sa hinaharap o sa mga teoretikal na Konsepto
sa likod ng Quantum computation na kasing halaga rin tingnan ang Understanding Quantum Information and Computation
na naka-host ni John Watrous halimbawa ngunit sa kursong ito aasumihin nating ang mag-aaral ay baka medyo mas maraming alam
kaysa dati at pupunta tayo nang napaka-teknikal at iyon ay dahil sa nakalipas na taon at sa
oras ng pagre-record na ito ay 2024 nakita natin ang isang pagbabago isang phase transition kung baga sa isang bagong era ng
computation ang mga quantum computer ay sa wakas ay papalapit sa puntong maaari silang maging kapaki-pakinabang kahit na ang pag-eeksperimento sa
maliliit na circuit at quantum computer ay kinakailangan para mapag-aralan ang ating komunidad kung paano gamitin ang mga makina walang nagpapatakbo ng mga eksperimento
na hindi rin maisasagawa sa regular na lumang klasikal na computer ngunit simula ngayon nakapasok na tayo sa isang era ng
quantum utility at ano ang utility maaari mong itanong ito ay naiiba sa Quantum Advantage na maaaring maunawaan sa
puntong ang mga quantum computer ay mas mahusay kaysa sa mga klasikal na computer sa isang makabuluhang gawain sa halip ang utility ay nangangahulugan
na maaari silang magsimulang makipagkumpetensya sa isa't isa at ito ang natural na susunod na hakbang sa teknolohikal
na Ebolusyon nag-publish ang IBM ng isang papel na nagpakita para sa unang pagkakataon noong nakaraang taon na ang isang quantum computer ay maaaring gamitin para
mag-simulate ng isang pisikal na modelo at makipagkumpetensya sa mga pinakabagong klasikal na simulation technique kahit nagtagumpay ito sa
mga Brute Force na pagtatangka at binigyan ang mga mananaliksik ng bagong daan na maaari nilang gamitin para sa pananaliksik kaya bakit lahat ng ito nangyayari
ngayon sa nakalipas na ilang buwan nagawa ng IBM na ma-access nang malawak ang mga Quantum processor na may higit sa 100 qubit kung ikaw ay
isang user na maaaring napansin mo na inalis namin ang marami sa aming mas maliliit na processor para bigyan ng daan ang mga mas malalaking chip at naramdaman namin na talagang
mahalaga para gawin ito dahil ang ilang bilang ng mga qubit ay maaaring pa rin ma-simulate nang klasikal nang walang problema kaya walang
tunay na kalamangan ang maaaring makuha sa paggamit ng mga chip na ito gayunpaman sa 100 qubit hindi na ito ang kaso hindi sila
maaaring ma-simulate nang klasikal mahalaga rin na tandaan na mayroong mga bagay na tinatawag na mga simulator na
essentially mga computer program at maaari nilang gayahin ang ilang gawi ng mga quantum system kabilang ang ingay gayunpaman pakiusap
huwag palampasin ang aking sinabi na gayahin ang mga simulator ay hindi quantum computer hindi sila makakapagbigay ng mga resulta na
magagawa ng mga quantum computer sa sukat na ito ngunit sila ay isang mahalagang bahagi pa rin ng aming testing workflow kaya iyon ay isang napaka-
mahabang sagot sa tanong sa tuktok ng slide na ito ano ang Practical Quantum Computing sa kursong ito ituturo ko sa iyo ang tungkol sa makatotohanang
potensyal na mga use case para sa Quantum at ang pinakamabuting mga kasanayan para sa pagpapatakbo at pag-eeksperimento sa mga mas malaking sukat
na processor ngayon kaya sino ang inilaan ng kursong ito magsimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng paggawa ng ilang level setting
sa simula ang kursong ito ay para sa lahat na naglalayong bumuo ng mga bagong aplikasyon para sa mga quantum computer gustong
malaman kung paano i-scale up ang kanilang kasalukuyang trabaho o matuto kung paano gamitin ang quantum sa kanilang mga kasalukuyang workflow dati ko nang
binanggit na ang kursong ito ay napaka-Hands-On at hindi namin tatalakayin ang mga teoretikal na aspeto nang madalas
inaasahan namin na pumasok ka na may pangunahing pag-unawa kung ano ang Quantum computation ngunit kung hindi ka pa naroon huwag mag-alala pakiusap panoorin lamang
ang unang ilang episode ng kurso ni John Watrous at magiging handa ka na gusto rin naming tiyakin na alam ng mga nanonood
na ito ay hindi lamang isang kurso para sa mga pisiko o kahit mga siyentipiko ng computer dalawang paksa na talagang nag-
hogging ng Quantum Computing sa nakalipas na dekada o kaya gusto naming tiyakin na ang iba na nagtatrabaho sa malaking data o
mga simulation tulad ng mga Inhinyero chemist at material scientist ay alam na ang kursong ito ay para sa kanila rin sa buod ang
kursong ito ay nakatuon sa malawak na audience at umaasa kami na sasama ka sa amin para sa kabuuan nito sa pagkumpleto ng kursong ito
magagawa mong maunawaan kung paano lumikha at magpatakbo ng isang utility scale job sa pamamagitan ng Qiskit runtime kabilang ang buong workflow
magagawa mong maunawaan ang mga pangunahing uri ng error mitigation at maunawaan din ang mga malamang na lugar ng aplikasyon sa maikling panahon magagawa mo ring
isagawa ang lahat ng algorithm na ito sa Qiskit at sa wakas inaasahan namin na magagawa mong maunawaan ang ingay at kung paano ito harapin
kaya magsimula na tayo ang Quantum Computing ay isang kapana-panabik na bagong teknolohiya sa maagang yugto ng pag-unlad ngunit ito ay
isang kabanata lamang sa kwento ng computation na bumabalik sa libu-libong taon sa palagay ko mahalagang maunawaan ang
kontekstong ito dahil ginagawa nitong mas intuitive na mahulaan at hindi gaanong
sci-fi ang aming layunin dito mula pa noong sinaunang panahon bilang mga tao kailangan nating magsagawa ng mga kalkulasyon o
sa madaling salita iproseso ang impormasyon ayon sa ilang tuntunin at hadlang para paganahin ang
komunikasyon konstruksyon Komersyo agham at lahat ng iba pang aspeto ng ating Buhay humingi tayo ng tulong sa pisikal na mundo
at sa pamamagitan ng matalinong mga natuklasan gumawa tayo ng mga device para tulungan tayo sa pag-compute noon ang mga device ay gawa sa
kahoy buto mga buhol na lubid at nag-iimbak ng impormasyon at nagpadali ng mga kalkulasyon nang ibang-iba kaysa ngayon
ang Mechanical na mga Device na gawa mula sa mga lever gear at iba pang makinarya ay lumago mula sa maagang mga astronomical clock hanggang sa
mga calculator hanggang sa mga sopistikadong Computing device tulad ng mga differential analyzer na nagresolba ng mga equation gamit ang mga gulong at
mga umiikot na disc kahit ang teknolohiya ng pagsulat ay gumanap ng mahalagang papel sa kwento sa pamamagitan ng pagpapahintulot sa mga tao na magsagawa
ng computation na hindi nila magagawa kung hindi kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa mga computer ngayon madalas nating iniisip ang tungkol sa
mga electronic digital computer ngunit ito ay medyo kamakailang teknolohiya ang mga electronic digital computer
ay unang itinayo noong 1940s ang pinaka-unang kilalang kasangkapan para sa computation ay ang Sumerian Abacus
na inaakala ng mga eksperto na naimbento sa Babylon noong 27 hanggang 2300 BC na talagang
matagal na ang nakaraan ngunit lalong naiintindihan natin ang natural na mundo mula kay Archimedes hanggang kay Euclid hanggang
kay Einstein ang ating pangangailangan ng mas maraming computational resources ay sumabog ngayon mayroon tayong mga supercomputer na
basically maraming napaka-makapangyarihang computer na nakakonekta nang parallel ang mga ito ay isa sa pinakamahusay na kasangkapan na mayroon ang sangkatauhan para sa
paglutas ng mga mahirap na problema ngunit mayroon pa ring maraming problema na kahit ang malalaking computer na ito ay hindi kailanman
malulutas higit pa rito sa susunod kaya naitatag na natin na ang mga tao ay gumagamit ng pisika at kalikasan para tulungan tayo na mag-compute
sa loob ng libu-libong taon at para tulungan tayo sa ating walang katapusang pagnanais na mag-compute ng mas marami at mas malalaking bagay maaaring alam mo na
ang Moore's Law ito ay hindi talaga isang batas kaya ito ay isang obserbasyon ang bahagi ng batas ay medyo
nagpapatawa sa aking opinyon ang maximum na bilang ng mga transistor sa isang integrated circuit basically isang computer chip
ay nagdoble ng halos bawat 2 taon sa nakalipas na 5 dekada o kaya hindi lamang tayo nakamasid nito kundi nagamit din natin nang malaki ang
mas maraming transistor kaya mas maraming mas mabilis na kalkulasyon ang maaari nating gawin ito ang essentially responsable para sa
paggawa ng mga computer na lalong makapangyarihan at mas maliit sa paglipas ng panahon gayunpaman may masamang balita ang Moore's Law ay namamatay
ang mga eksperto ay nagtatalo kung kailan maaaring maabot ang katapusan ng Moore's Law ngunit ang ilan ay nagsasabi na nangyari na ito kahit hindi tayo
sigurado kung kailan maaabot ang ating limitasyon alam natin na ito ay sa huli ay hindi maiiwasan dahil ang ilang bahagi ng transistor
ay hindi maaaring gawing mas maliit pa nang pisikal hindi ka makakagawa ng transistor na mas maliit sa isang atom halimbawa ito
ay siyempre ganap na hindi pisikal mukhang katawa-tawa ngunit iyon ang mga limitasyon na talagang kinakaharap natin kaya ano ang
gagawin natin basta susukokin at sasabihing hey ganyan na lang ang pinakamabuti hindi kailanman ginawa ng mga tao iyon sa kabutihang palad ang quantum
mechanics ay pumasok sa usapin natuklasan ang quantum mechanics noong 1920s at mula noon ang mundo ay
literal na hindi na naging pareho at maaari tayong gumugol ng mga oras na nag-uusap tungkol sa mga rebolusyonaryong natuklasan na
nagawa ngunit hindi talaga iyon ang pokus ng kursong ito sa halip gusto kong linawin na alam natin na ang quantum
mechanics at Computing ay magkatugma na sa isa't isa ang mga natuklasan at pag-unawa sa kalikasan
na natutunan natin mula sa quantum mechanics ay bahagyang nagpagana sa ating mga modernong computer nang wala ang quantum
mechanics hindi natin mauunawaan o malamang hindi pa natin nagawa ang solid state hard drive halimbawa ang Quantum computation ay simpleng susunod na natural na hakbang sa Ebolusyong ito
ngunit ang computation ay hindi lamang umiiral sa isang bakuran ang impormasyon ay nangangailangan ng medium
ang pag-compute ng impormasyon ay gumagamit ng pisikal na mundo at nakakaapekto rin ito dito naglalagay ito ng mga limitasyon sa kung ano ang posible
ngunit ang pag-unawa sa kalikasan at sa mga pisikal na limitasyon ay talagang layunin ng pisika bilang isang
disiplina kaya sa isang paraan ang pisika at computation ay palaging magkaugnay si Ralph Landauer isang siyentipiko ng computer at isang
IBMer ay nakilala ng ilang dekada na ang nakaraan na ang impormasyon ay pisikal sa madaling salita ang impormasyon ay hindi isang
abstract na entidad kundi umiiral lamang sa pamamagitan ng pisikal na representasyon ang prinsipyo ni Landauer ay nagtatatag ng koneksyon
sa pagitan ng impormasyon at ng mga batas ng thermodynamics ngunit sa katunayan maraming koneksyon sa pagitan ng pisika at
computation ang klasikal na pisika ang tanging naabot natin hanggang kamakailan ngunit sa pagtuklas ng quantum
mechanics ngayon tayo ay nasa gilid ng pagiging makalikha ng ganap na bagong paraan ng pag-compute at ito ay napakaganda dahil
ang mga klasikal na computer ay maaari lamang mag-approximate ng kung ano ang talagang nagaganap sa kalikasan at sa ilang kaso ang approximation na iyon ay napaka-
limitado iyon ay dahil talagang napakahirap gawing magsumusunod ang mga makina na sumusunod sa mga batas ng klasikal na pisika
sa pag-approximate ng mga batas ng quantum physics at ang kalikasan ay hindi klasikal ito ay quantum isang analogy na maaaring makatulong sa iyo
na maunawaan ay isang wind tunnel ang fluid dynamics ay kilala-kilala na mahirap i-simulate at hulaan nang matematika
kahit ang isang bagay na kasing mundane ng isang kotse na nagmamaneho sa hangin natuklasan ng mga manufacturer ng sasakyan na talagang
masyadong mahal at hindi praktikal na subukang i-simulate ang pisikal na interaksyong ito nang nagdidisenyo sila ng mga sasakyan sa halip ang
ginawa nila ay gumawa ng literal na tunnel na nagpapalabas ng hangin at nagmamaneho lang ng sasakyan papasok sa tunnel
at tingnan kung paano ito gumaganap ito ay kahalintulad ng aking ibig sabihin kapag sinabi ko na ang mga klasikal na computer ay mahina lamang ang
pag-approximate ng kalikasan at minsan masyadong mahal kahit subukan silang gawin niyon sa halip na i-simulate ang hangin ang
mga mananaliksik ay ginagawang muli ito nang katulad ang mga quantum computer ay hindi kailangang mag-approximate ng mga batas ng kalikasan sa
molecular na antas dahil sinusunod nila ang mga batas na iyon nang likas hindi sila kailangang mag-simulate ng anumang bagay inilalabas nila ito at
ang parehong mga kahirapan ay lumabas kapag nagsi-simulate tayo ng mga baterya o mga reaksyong kemikal na nagdadala sa atin sa aming susunod na
seksyon Quantum Computing ano ang mabuti para dito kaya
bakit natin gusto ang isipin ang pagsasama ng quantum mechanics at Computing well marami na tayong sapat
na mga problema na masyadong mahirap masyadong computationally costly kahit para sa ating pinakabagong mga supercomputer na malutas
baka ang mga ito ay mga problemang nakatutok lamang ang mga mananaliksik ngunit ang kanilang mga epekto ay maaaring makaapekto sa lahat ng bahagi ng
mundo ang mga problemang ito na naiistrik ang mga klasikal na computer ay mga bagay na bilang isang Lipunan lalong nagiging mas
umaasa tayo sa teknolohiya at talagang nagmamalasakit tulad ng kahusayan ng baterya Financial modeling at
optimization at kahit kung paano gumawa ng mas magagandang eroplano kaya bakit lumingon sa mga quantum computer mayroon kaming napakamabuting dahilan
na mag-isip na maraming potensyal dito at maaari tayong magbukas ng mga pinto sa bagong computation na kasalukuyang wala sa kakayahan kahit ng
pinaka-makapangyarihang mga supercomputer sa teorya ang ilang Quantum algorithm ay nagbibigay ng mga kalamangan kaysa sa
pinakamabuting posibleng klasikal na algorithm para sa ilang mga aplikasyon para sa iba pang mga aplikasyon mayroon pang lumalaking ebidensya na kahit
na may ingay at Kapintasan ang mga quantum computer ay maaari pa ring gamitin bilang kasangkapan para makipagkumpetensya sa klasikal na brute
force solution basically ito ay isang brand new na kasangkapan at gusto naming malaman ang mas maraming kool na bagay na maaari nating gawin gamit ito ngunit maaari rin nating
tingnan ang orihinal na ideya ni Feynman para sa kanila na gamitin ang mga ito para maunawaan ang pisika at kalikasan sa at ng sarili nito
pagkatapos ng lahat sinabi ko na sa iyo na ang kalikasan ay quantum hindi klasikal at ang larangang ito ay hindi kapani-paniwalang mayaman kamangha-mangha at
interdisciplinary nagbubuklod ito ng pisika siyentipiko ng computer pagpoproseso ng impormasyon at siyempre ang mga tiyak na domain ng mga lugar ng aplikasyon na
maaaring interesado tayo gayunpaman hindi tulad ng mga klasikal na computer hindi lahat ay may quantum computer na nakatago sa kanilang
bulsa hanggang kamakailan kung gusto mong mag-eksperimento sa isang quantum computer kailangan mong itayo at mapanatili ang
isa nang ikaw mismo karaniwang sa isang malungkot na silong lab sa isang unibersidad o research facility at magtiwala ka sa aking sasabihin alam ko iyon hindi na
ito ang kaso gayunpaman noong 2016 inilagay ng IBM ang unang Quantum processor sa cloud mayroon itong limang qubit lamang sa oras na iyon at
medyo mataas na mga rate ng error ngunit iyon ay 8 taon lamang ang nakaraan at tingnan kung gaano na tayo kalayo kaya nasaan na tayo ngayon
maraming kaparalelo na maaaring makuha sa mga napakamaagang araw ng modernong computer tulad ng nabanggit ko ito ay isang napaka-
mahirap na Hamon at 8 taon lamang ang nakalipas nang ang mga quantum computer ay naging malawak na available bukod sa
mga nagtatrabaho sa isang Cutting Edge lab o pasilidad ngunit sa nakalipas na walong taon nagawa namin ang pag-unlad sa bawat
harapan ang mga processor ay mas malaki nang mga order of magnitude sa laki ng qubit ang mga gate ay lubhang napabuti at nagpakilala kami ng mga pamamaraan
ng pagbabawas o pagpapagaan ng mga error na likas sa mga quantum system kahit habang tinutulak namin ang pasulong para lumikha ng fault
tolerant na mga quantum computer ngayon ikaw at sinumang iba pa ay maaaring gumamit ng isa sa maraming IBM Quantum processor na
naka-host sa cloud halos lahat ay ang pinakabago pinakahuli at pinakamahusay na mga sistema na may higit sa 100
qubit ngunit ang laki ng mga processor lamang ang mahalaga ito ay isang metric lamang na pinahahalagahan natin at
makatuwiran iyon di ba kung mas maraming qubit mayroon tayo iyon ay mas maganda basta ang pagtaas ng bilang ng mga qubit
ay hindi nagpapababa ng performance gayunpaman hindi ito palaging ganoon kailangan namin ng mas maraming de-kalidad na qubit na hindi makakasama
sa isa't isa sa pamamagitan ng cross talk kapag hindi namin nais iyon kung paano nakakonekta ang mga qubit sa isa't isa ay mahalaga rin na tandaan sa
superconducting circuit ito ay isang hamon para malaman kung paano pinakamahusay na pisikal na ikonekta ang mga qubit isa pang napaka-mahalagang metric
ay ang two-qubit gate fidelity ang mga gate na tumatakbo sa single qubit ay hindi gaanong madaling magkamali ang two-qubit gate ang
mas malaking lugar ng pag-aalala at karaniwang isa sa mga go-to metric na hinahanap natin para makita kung paano nagpapabuti ang performance sa
paglipas ng panahon ang two-qubit gate ay napakahalaga na maayos na maipatupad dahil sila ay responsable para sa paglikha ng entanglement sa pagitan ng mga qubit
na isa sa mga phenomena ng pisika na nagbibigay ng kapangyarihan sa mga quantum computer sa wakas hinahanap namin ang Bilis at kahusayan
kailangan naming tiyakin na ang oras na ginugugol sa pagpapatakbo ng programa sa quantum chip ay isinasagawa nang mabilis at mahusay
hangga't maaari tinutukoy namin ang tatlong metric na ito nang sama-sama bilang sukat kalidad at
bilis lahat ng mga ito ay mahalaga para mapabuti ang performance ngayon gusto kong ipakita sa iyo ang ilang mabilis na plot para i-back up ang aking mga
sinasabi tungkol sa kung paano ang teknolohiya mismo ay tunay na mabilis na umuunlad ang bilang ng qubit mismo ay pinaka-madaling
maunawaan sa palagay ko at nag-publish ang IBM ng road map kung saan tayo umaasa na maroroon sa susunod na ilang taon sa mga tuntunin ng bilang ng qubit
at laki ng processor para sa 2024 kapag inire-record namin ang video na ito tayo ay tumpak na nasa tamang landas na may aming processor na Heron at Condor susunod
ang kalidad ang plot na ito ay nagpapakita ng median entangling gate error rate para sa mga IBM Quantum processor sa paglipas ng panahon panatilihin sa
isip na ito ay isang log scale kaya habang ang pag-unlad ay mukhang bahagyang linear ito ay talagang mas mabilis kaysa sa iyon
sa wakas mayroon tayong bilis ang graph na ito ay nagpapakita ng pag-unlad ng isang metric na tinatawag naming CLOPS na kumakatawan sa circuit layer
operations per second mahalaga ang CLOPS ay sumasaklaw sa parehong oras na kinakailangan para patakbuhin ang mga circuit at ang kinakailangang real at
near-time classical compute basically ang CLOPS ay isang sukatan ng kung gaano kabilis ang aming mga processor ay makakapatakbo ng mga tiyak na circuit sa
serye na nagsisilbing sukatan ng holistic system speed at nagsasama ng Quantum at klasikal
na Computing ngayon sa oras ng pagre-record ang IBM ang tanging Quantum cloud provider na nagbibigay ng access sa 100
dagdag na qubit machine tulad ng nabanggit ko ilang slide na ang nakaraan ang 100 qubit o mga paligid doon ay kung saan ang klasikal na simulation
ay nagsisimulang ganap na mabigo kaya ang malalaking scale na trabaho na pinapatakbo sa mga makina na ito ay madalas na walang klasikal na katumbas hindi ito
posible mayroong ilang nuance at ilang mga tips at tricks na maaari mong gamitin para i-simulate ang ilang bahagi ng isang circuit at pagkatapos ang iba
bahagi nang hiwalay ngunit sa pangkalahatan alam namin na malapit sa bilang na ito ay kung saan ang mga quantum computer ay maaaring magsimulang gumawa ng mga bagay na hindi magagawa ng mga klasikal na computer kaya
napagpasyahan ng IBM na ang pagbibigay ng access sa mga mas malalaking device na ito ay napakahalaga para sa mas malawak na Komunidad dahil ang anumang
ginagawa sa mas maliliit na device ay classically simulatable kaya hindi ito makakahantong sa Quantum Advantage ang 100 qubit
device na mayroon tayo ngayon ay may depekto pa rin at maingay pa rin kaya kailangan nating maging matalino sa kung paano natin patakbuhin ang mga trabaho at
mga circuit sa kanila ang walang pag-iingat na simpleng pagsulat ng aming circuit at pagpindot sa shift enter ay malamang na hindi hahantong sa anumang
espektakulo ngunit muli mayroong mga tips at tricks na maaari naming ipatupad at pinakamabuting mga kasanayan na maaari naming sundin para mapiga ang kahit
mas maraming performance mula sa mga device na ito na, sana, ay hahantong sa Quantum Advantage nang mas maaga kahit habang patuloy kaming nagtatrabaho
at nagtatayo ng aming mga fault tolerant na makina pati na rin ang plot na ito ay nagpapakita ng halaga ng simulation
o ang dami ng oras na kinakailangan para malutas ang isang problema sa mga klasikal na computer at mga quantum computer na nilagyan ng error
mitigation at error correction kaya ang linya ng klasikal na computation ay nag-i-scale nang exponentially habang ang pagiging kumplikado ng circuit
ay lumalaki para sa mga simpleng circuit dito hindi iyon mahalaga ngunit malinaw na masamang habang lumalaki ang pagiging kumplikado dahil ito
ay nagpapagastos ng simulation nang napakabilis ang error mitigation ay nag-i-scale nang mas mahusay kaya kapag lumaki ang pagiging kumplikado ng
circuit doon tayo gustong maroroon kasalukuyan tayo dito na may mga klasikal na pamamaraan at Quantum na pamamaraan na medyo katumbas
para sa ilang aplikasyon at ang error correction ay maaaring ang pinaka-kanais-nais at nag-i-scale nang napakahusay
wala lang tayo doon pa hindi pa ngayon sa samantala magpapatuloy tayong mag-focus sa error mitigation at sa pagdating sa
lugar ng quantum utility nang mabilis hangga't maaari at sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng ilang error mitigation scheme na
matututunan natin sa seryeng ito layunin naming mahanap ang mga lugar ng aplikasyon na maaaring gumamit ng quantum utility nang mabilis at iyon ang
talagang puso ng kursong ito mayroon tayo ng mga makina na ito sa palagay namin ay kayang gumawa ng ilang talagang kawili-wiling
pananaliksik kaya paano natin gagamitin ang mga ito sa huling seksyon ng episode hayaan nating talakayin nang maikli ang mga lugar ng aplikasyon para sa
praktikal na Quantum Computing mayroong tatlong pangunahing sangay na sa palagay namin ay pinaka-nasasabik naming tuklasin at mahanap ng mga paraan para sa Quantum
utility ang una ay ang pag-simulate ng kalikasan ito ay may kaugnayan sa pag-simulate ng mga molecular o atomic na interaksyon at ito ay
napakahalaga para sa mga larangan ng material science at chemistry at dahil sa mga dahilang tinalakay natin nang mas maaga sa palagay namin ang quantum
computer ay magiging mas mahusay dito kaysa sa kanilang mga katumbas na klasikal na computer susunod ay ang paghahanap at
optimization ang pangunahing algorithm ng interes dito ay tinatawag na QAOA isang hybrid classical-quantum algorithm ang QAOA ay gumagamit ng isang
klasikal na computer para sanayin at mahanap ang Optimal na mga parameter para sa isang Quantum circuit at umaasa tayong magagawa nating gawin ito nang
mas mahusay kaysa sa alinmang computer nang mag-isa sa wakas mayroon tayong matematika at pagpoproseso ng data na may istruktura ang quantum
computer ay mahusay sa paghahanap ng istruktura sa magulong data kung saan maaaring wala kang o ako o isang karaniwang computer ay makakita ng
anumang bagay ang Quantum machine learning ay may pangako sa larangang ito at layunin nating gamitin ito para sa mga gawain tulad ng feature
extraction at pattern recognition ito ay talagang napaka-kapana-panabik na panahon para sa atin na nagtatrabaho sa
larangan ng quantum Computing para sa unang pagkakataon sa kasaysayan maaari na tayong magsimulang tuklasin ang isang rehiyon ng computing na higit pa sa
klasikal na Computing ang ilan sa inyo na nanonood nito ay maaaring gumanap ng katulad na papel sa mga maagang pioneer ng
computing at wala silang konsepto kung ano ang susunod si T. J. Watson ng IBM ay kilalang nagsabi na sa tingin niya mayroon lamang
merkado para sa dalawa o tatlong computer lang kailanman at wow mali siya tayo ay
lahat ang mga maagang pioneer na iyon ng computing ngunit sa bagong larangang ito ng quantum Computing at ang Quantum ay madalas na
inihahambing sa klasikal na Computing bilang isang bagay na kakaibang iba sa ito at madalas na nakikipagkumpetensya dito ngunit ang aking
layunin para sa pambungad na leksyong ito ay sana makahadlok sa iyo na mula sa pananaw ng agila maaari nating makita ang Quantum
Computing bilang simpleng susunod na kabanata sa mahabang kwento ng computing ito ay ating kalikasan bilang mga tao na hanapin ang mga bagong paraan para
mag-compute at gamitin ang kapangyarihan ng natural na mundo at malaman kung ano ang gagawin dito at ginagawa natin ito sa loob ng
mga siglo ang Quantum Computing ay nag-aalok sa atin ng bagong kasangkapan sa pagsisikap na ito at nasa atin ito para tuklasin kung paano natin magagamit
ang kapangyarihang inaalok nito sa atin sa susunod na aralin sa seryeng ito maguusap tayo nang kaunti pa tungkol sa 100 qubit system
at magbibigay ng pangkalahatang-ideya ng Qiskit ang aming quantum software SDK at kung paano pinakamahusay na makipag-ugnayan sa mga makina na ito ngayon salamat sa
panonood at kita tayo sa susunod na pagkakataon